[موسيقى]
الله اوقاتكم بكل خير نواصل هذه التغطيه
من قناه العربيه حيث يحيي العالم اليوم
الذكرى السنويه الاولى للحرب في اوكرانيا
حرب سببت الكثير من الدمار والقتل والتشرد
فضلا عن ازمات عالميه متعدده
فثلث سكان اوكرانيا اجبروا على الفرار من
ديارهم خلال هذا العام وهناك سباق للتسلح
والتسليح بين الدول
ومخاوف من تمدد الحرب الى مناطق اخرى
وفي الذكرى الاولى للحرب ومع العقوبات
الجديده التي فرضها الغرب اليوم على روسيا
توالت التحذيرات من توتر الاوضاع في الدول
المجاوره موسكو حذرت الغرب من اي استفزاز
عسكري اوكراني في منطقه ترانسدنستريا
الانفصاليه المواليه لها في وقت تستعر فيه
المعارك على اكثر من جبهه في الدوناتس هذا
فيما تسعى بولندا لتسليم اولى دبابات
ليوبارد الى كييف في ظل وعود غربيه بعدم
ترك اوكرانيا وحيده ومنع روسيا من تحقيق
النصر
[موسيقى]
وفي الذكرى السنويه الاولى للحرب قال وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني اوريكسي ريزنكوف ان
قواته تخطط لطرد القوات الروسيه من جميع
الاراضي الاوكرانيه مضيفا ان بلاده كان
يصعب عليها قبل عام الحصول على اسلحه
حديثه كما اشار وزير الدفاع الاوكراني لان
الدول المتحضره ترى اوكرانيا درعا لها
متوقعا هجوما مضادا خلال الفتره المقبله
في غضون ذلك توقع نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي ديمتريديف ان تنتصر روسيا وان يضع
شكل من اشكال الاتفاقات الفاضه حدا لهذه
الحرب
ورامدب ان الوسيله الوحيده امام موسكو
لضمان السلام الدائم في اوكرانيا هي دفع
حدود الدول المعاديه الى الوراء قدر
الامكان حتى وان كان ذلك يعني حدود بولندا
العضو في حلف شمال الاطلسي
بولندا حدود شرقيه طويله مع اوكرانيا
وبيلاروسيا حليفه موسكو الى جانب حدود
بمسافه نحو 200 كيلومتر في شمال شرقها مع
جيب الروسي
الى شبكه مراسلين في هذه التغطيه مع حذيفه
عادل من موسكو مراسله العربيه ومن واشنطن
مراسل العربيه برغانم ابدا معك حذيفه كيف
عاش الاوكرانيون هذا اليوم وهل يتوقعون
الاسوء في السنه المقبله وان هذه الحرب
ستطول وتطول
تحياتي طالب يومين من الانتظار والترقب
عاشها الاوكرانيين ينتظرون ان في يوم
الذكرى سوف تكون عمليه هجوم واسعه النطاق
من قبل الاتحاد الروسي وسيكون هنالك عمليه
اطلاق واسعه للصواريخ تستهدف جميع المدن
الاوكرانيه الامر الذي لم يحدث لاحظنا ان
المواطنين هجروا المدن ولجوا الى الريفكا
اجراء وقائي قبل الذكرة السنويه اليوم مرت
بشكل طبيعي وهادئ جدا لاحظنا ان الشوارع
خاليه تماما اغلبيه المواطنين بقوا في
منازلهم اولىجوا الى البيوت الريفيه تم
نقل الدراسه الى وضع الوضع الافتراضي لم
يذهب الطلاب الى المدارس اعتقد ان حتى
الموظفين معظمهم لم يذهبوا بنسبه لما نراه
في الشوارع من حركه خفيفه جدا الناس
يتجولون فقط في مناطق قريبه من منازلهم
على المستوى الرسمي خاطب الرئيس
فلاديميرسكي اليوم خطابا للشعب الاوكراني
وارسل رساله رساله كانت في الصباح الباكر
من خلال هذه الرساله اتحدث الى فئات
المجتمع المختلفه الى المتطوعين الذين كان
لهم دور كبير جدا في صمود الشعب الاوكراني
طوال هذا العام خاطب ومن هم اولئك خارج
الحدود الاوكرانيه الذين اصبحوا لاجئين
وكذلك من هم في الاراضي التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا وكذلك المتطوعين الذين انضموا الى
الجيش الاوكراني وكذلك القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه وايضا بعد ذلك كان له خطاب في
وجود قواته المسلحه يعني سلمهم الويه
المعركه والويه الجيش وكذلك الميداليات
القوات
سانتقل الى كاتيا من موسكو كاتيا كيف احيا
الروس هذا اليوم وهل بات الجميع في روسيا
متيقن ان هذه الحرب فتحت لتبقى وتستمر دون
اي افق للحل
مرحبا طالب حقيقه روسيا ومنذ ثلاثه ايام
تحتفل كانت بمناسبه اولا الدفاع يوم
المدافع عن الوطن الذي شهدته طبعا موسكو
يوم امس ومن قبلها كان هناك كلمه للرئيس
الروسي الى الجمعيه الفيدراليه ايضا تحدث
فيها عن الذكرى السنويه للعمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا اليوم كان هناك طبعا
تصريح
لنائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسيه
الذي تحدث عن تحدث عن ان روسيا ستنتصر
بالتاكيد في هذه العمليه العسكريه التي
بداتها في اوكرانيا وان طبعا الغرب كان
يهدف الى
هزيمه روسيا من خلال هذه الحرب في
اوكرانيا طبعا الشارع الروسي طالب حتى
الان يعيش في ضبابيه لان العمليه العسكريه
الان ومن خطابات الرئيس المتكرره التي
شهدناها خلال الايام الاخيره هم يستشف
فيما اذا كان هناك نهايه قريبه لهذه
العمليه العسكريه التي بداتها روسيا في
اوكرانيا طيب ابقي معي الى فير غانم بيير
كيف مر هذا اليوم
امريكيا وهل الراي العام الامريكي باتا
اقرب الى اليقين بان ما يجري هو حرب
مباشره امريكيه روسيه مع العلم انها في
الظاهر حرب اوكرانيه روسيه
نحن في بدايه النهار هنا والرئيس
الامريكيه يتحدث الان الى نظرائه من
مجموعه الدول الصناعيه السبع هذا الاجتماع
من خلال ازوم هو بحد ذاته مؤشر مهم جدا
على موقف الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مما
يحدث في اوكرانيا الامريكيون الرئيس بايدن
بشكل خاص يعتبر ان وقوف العالم صفا واحدا
خصوصا العالم الصناعي ضد روسيا والى جانب
اوكرانيا هو نموذج كيف تحبط الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه المساعي الروسيه
الحربيه بضم اراض او اسقاط النظام في
اوكرانيا من دون ان يذهب جندي امريكي الى
ارض المعركه ووقوف الدول الصناعيه الى
جانب الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هو ايضا
نجاح للدبلوماسيه الامريكيه هكذا يرى
البيت الابيض هذا هذه الخطوه في هذا
الصباح وهذه القمه بالنسبه
للامريكيين عامه يعتبرون ان الاداره
الامريكيه تقوم بواجب ضروري وهو مساعده
الاوكرانيين في الدفاع عن انفسهم
يعتبر الامريكيون ان عدم ارسال جدود
امريكيين الى ارض المعركه هو نجاح كبير
لهم نستطيع ان نسمي هذه المواجهه ما شئنا
مواجهه بين الاوكرانيين او الروس او بين
روسيا والعالم بما فيه الحرب بالوكاله او
الحرب غير المباشره ولكن الدرس الاساسي
الذي يراه الامريكيون هو انهم اولا ليسوا
على ارض المعركه ثانيا فشل اوكرانيا يعني
الدخول في متاهات كثيره بما فيها التدخل
المباشر الامريكي وهذا ما لا يريدونه من
واشنطن مراسل العربيه
بايرن جزيلا لك شكرا ايضا
موسكو ولحذيفه عادل كان معي
من الصعب الاماكن التي تركز فيها
القصف يدعوننا للدخول داخل الملجا
يجب ان نتوجه معهم الى مكان امن
هو ليس اتفاق في الشارع وانه اصطدام على
محطات الوقت
تعاطف كبير مع اللاجئين الاوكرانيين
[موسيقى]
هو رائحه الحرير
هذا مثلا صفاره الانذار اليوم كل ما خرجنا
من وسط العاصمه تزيد حده الاصوات
50 مترا بثمانيه والكمال تفصيلنا عن مصنع
ازوفل
[موسيقى]
طبعا من يشاهد هذا المنظر يعتقد انه حريق
لهذه البنايات ولكن لكميه الاستهداف
[موسيقى]
عبد الله صاحب بزنس عنده متجر صغيره
وطلبات ما توقف الموضوع مو بس جوده منتجات
سرعه التوصيل عنده تجاوزت التوقعات ما
تلحق الزبائن تطلب تلقى تلفونهم يدق وبوقت
قصير كل الطلب
اتي
ومستودعات تخزين تعمل كوسيط تربط اصحاب
المتاجر والمشاريع بعملائهم بشكل سهل
وبسيط
والسع حدودك
يشعر المرء بضروره للتساؤل
للاستفسار
عن قضايا تهم الملايين حول العالم يشعر
المرء بحاجه لايجاد اجابات
عن اسئله تشكل الحاضر والمستقبل
كل الاسئله تطرح وكل الاخبار تناقش
[موسيقى]
التفاصيل نقف عندها
استخدام معجون اسنان مخصص لحساسيه الاسنان
لا يعني بالضروره التنازل عن فوائد معجون
الاسنان الاخرى السودان الحمايه المتكامل
بلس يحتوي على الكثير من الفوائد ام يزهى
الحمايه من الحساسيه الاسنان حمايه
الاسنان لتسوسات السودان الحمايه
المتكامله بلس يعتبر الخيار مناسب جدا
لاستخدامه كروتين يومي صحي للحمايه من
حساسيه الاسنان وعدم التنازل عن فوائد
معجون الاسنان الاخرى
[موسيقى]
نبض السوق
في هذه الاوقات على شاشه العربيه
يد الام يا مشاف الطول هالمشوار
ومع هذا لسا تعرف كيف تختار حليب المراعي
الطازج الفرق بيدين الامهات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه التغطيه في اول
مقابله من نوعها مع وسيله اعلاميه عربيه
قالت سيده اوكرانيا الاولى اولينا
زيلينسكي انها تبذل ما في وسعها وتحاول كل
جهدها من اجل الانتصار في هذه الحرب ضد
روسيا
وقبل كل شيء سابدا بحقيقه ان لا احد يجهزك
على الاطلاق كيف تكونين سيده اولى خصوصا
في حاله الحرب ولا احد يجهزك لحقيقه انه
يجب ان تكونين زوجه رئيس دوله في حاله حرب
ولكن كما قال داروين ليس الاسرع او الاقوى
من ينجو ولكن اولئك الذين يمكنهم التكيف
لذلك اعتقد انني اعمل وفق متطلبات العصر
حسب مقتضيات الظروف التي نعيش فيها احاول
ان افعل كل ما يجب علي من اجل تقريب
انتصارنا والشيء الاكثر اهميه هو التحدث
عن اوكرانيا عن الاوكرانيين في اي منصه
حيث اتيحت للفرصه للتحدث
اعزائي المشاهدين تشاهدون مقابله العربيه
الكامله مع سيده اوكرانيا الاولى بعد قليل
في هذه النشره
[موسيقى]
اعتبرت الخارجيه الصينيه ان انتقاد
الوثيقه الصينيه بشان التسويه السياسيه
لازمه اوكرانيا يمثل محاوله غير مبرره
لتشويه سمعه الصين
واشارت الى ضروره التمييز بين من يساهم
بشكل حقيقي في البحث عن حل سلمي ومن يساهم
في زياده التوتر والتصعيد
وكانت الخارجيه الصينيه قد نشرت في وقت
سابق وثيقه مكونه من اثني عشر بندر تعرض
فيها موقفين من التسويه السياسيه
للازمه الاوكرانيه
لمزيد من المتابعه في هذه التغطيه معي من
ابوظبي الان عبر تقنيه الزوم الدبلوماسيه
الاوكرانيه فيتالي فيتيالين ومن موسكو
المحلل السياسي فيني
ابدا معك لنترك حسابات الحقل وحسابات
البيدر جانبا حول ما الات هذه الحرب ما
الذي تحقق وما الذي لم يتحقق بالنسبه الى
الروس هل ثمه افق للحل في الاشهر المقبله
ام لا هذه الحرب ستطول وتطول جدا بالنسبه
اليك
المشاهدين والديفك الكريم بالنسبه للمدى
القريب والمدى المنظور انا لا اعتقد بان
هناك افاق واقعيه للحل ولكن هناك مؤشرات
ربما مبطنه على ان الحل يمكن ان يحدث او
محاولات التواصل الى هذا الحل يمكن ان
تحدث ربما في هذه السنه
تحديدا متى سيحدث ذلك من الصعب ان نتكاها
به الان ولكن يبدو ان هناك بالاضافه الى
المبادره الصينيه وبالمناسبه الصين تسميها
بورقه عمل وليس بخطه سلام شامله مثلا
بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك محاولات كما قلنا
من مختلف الاطراف من تركيا وكذلك حتى من
الدول الغربيه لانها ايضا قادتها يرسلون
بين الفين والاخرى اشارات مبطنه على
امكانيه البدء بمفاوضات سياسيه مع طرفي
الصراع ولكن الان برايي من المبكر جدا
الحديث عن مثل هذا التطور خلال الاشهر
القريبه القادمه لا في وقت ينتظر فيه
الكثيرون هجوما روسيا
وربما هجوما اوكرانيا مضادا في شتى جبهات
القتال وبالتالي ربما على اساس نتائج ما
سوف تسفر عنه المعارك القادمه اذا وقعت
على الارض في الوقت القريب سوف يكون
بالامكان الحكم على افاق الحل السياسي
والعوده الى المفاوضات دعني انتقل الى
السيد فيتالي في ابوظبي سيد فيتالي سمعت
السيد سيدي روب اولا بعد سنه من هذه الحرب
هل اقترب الاوكرانيون الى حقيقه مفادها
اللا بديل عن حل تفاوض على الطاوله لان
استمرار الحرب بهذه الوتيره هو
كارثه كبرى تهدد مستقبل اوكرانيا برمته
يعني حتى زوال اوكرانيا عن الخارطه كما
يقول البعض
طبعا السؤال نهايه الحرب صعب جدا ولا احد
يمكن ان نتنبا يعني لمعه المحدد لانتهاء
او نهايه هذه الحرب ولكن يعني من جانب من
جانبنا لا تسال عن الى متى ستستمر هذه
الحرب يعني افضل ان تسال عن كيفيه مساعده
اوكرانيا على الانتصار بشكل اسرع لان كل
ما اسرع شركائنا في التزويد اوكرانيا
بالمساعدات العسكريه الان كلما ازدادت
القدرات الاوكرانيه على الانتصار وانتهت
الحرب في اقرب وقت ممكن بالسلام شامل واهم
شيء عادل ودائم لاوكرانيا ولا احد من
شركائنا مهدم بحرف استنزاف طويله التي
تتطوق موارد اضافيه طبعا وتؤدي الى خسائر
بشريه مؤلمه
وفي نفس الوقت في نفس الوقت
اوضحت اوضحت اوكرانيا بشكل صريح اننا لن
نقبل السلام باي ثمن ولن نوافق على
الاتفاقات التي ستبقي الاراضي الاوكرانيه
تحت الاحتلال الروسي وشعبنا تحت رحمه
المعتدل روسي يجب ايقاع في روسيا الان لان
استرضاع المعتدسه يؤدي الى المزيد من
الفضائل الفضائع والمزاعات والحروب في
اماكن اخرى
هل تشكل ورقه العمل الصينيه فرصه جيده يجب
استثمارها وهل استشارت بكين موسكو حول
بنود خطه العمل هذه قبل طرحها وهل توافق
موسكو على كل هذه البنود
انا ليه اعتقد بان الجانب الروسي الان
مستعد
لابداع رد فعلها على هذه المبادره لانه لم
يكشر حتى الان عن تفاصيلها ومنها ربما اهم
ما يمكن
تحتوي عليه هذه الورقه هي موقف الصين
اضاءه شروط الانتهاء من العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه التي تقودها روسيا هل الصين ربما
جاهز للتعاطي مع الامر الواقع اي ما يحدث
على الارض ام انه ربما دعت موسكو الى
الانسحاب من
تلك المناطق التي كانت قد تم السيطره
عليها خلال السنه من العمليه العسكريه
يعني هذه النكته مهمه جدا لكي ندرك طبيعه
المقترح الصيني وطبيعه الرد الروسي لكن
واضح تماما ان روسيا يعني على الاقل انا
اعتقد الان ان روسيا لن تقبل باندا يخص
انسحاب قواتها من الاراضي التي تم السيطره
عليها حتى اذا عرضت الصين على روسيا مثل
هذه الصيغه كما انه اوكرانيا اخرى لن تقبل
ان اي باندا بهذه الخطه الصينيه ورقه عمل
الصينيه يتضمن ربما اعترافا ضمنيا او
مبطنا من قبل اوكرانيا
بالسيطره روسيه
لاسال السيد فيتالي سيد فيتالي لماذا سارى
اطراف اوكرانيه الى رفض ورقه العمل
الصينيه يعني حتى انها لم تطرح بشكل رسمي
وعلني لماذا سارعوا الى رفضها
ولا تثقين ام لا تعتبرها طرفا الى جانب
روسيا وهنا يعني مربط الفرس وهنا سبب
الرفض
اولا عندنا صيغه السلام الخاصه الرئيس
الاوكراني قدمت صيغه اوكرانيا للسلام في
اجتماع يعني مجموعه سبعه الكبرى
ويعني النقطه الثانيه كانت منذ البدايه
نحن الموافقون على المفاوضات ولكن بعد
الانسحاب القوات الروسيه من ارضنا فقط لان
نحن نعتقد واثقون ان اي مفاوضات قبل
الانسحاب الروسي من ارضنا
ستظهر وتساعد في اطفاء الشرعيه على احتلال
ارض
الاوكرانيه والنقطه الثالثه مهمه جدا لان
امس نحن شفنا كيف
اتبنت جمعيه العامه للامم المتحده القرار
القرار المهم المبني على صيغه اوكرانيا
للسلام و141 دوله تؤيد اوكرانيا وسلامتها
الاقليميه وتدعو الى الانسحاب الفوري
للقوات الاحتلال الروسيه من اراد
ساكتفي بهذا القدر للاسف هذا وقت المقابله
من ابو ظبي عبر تقنيه الزوم الدبلوماسي
الاوكراني فيتالي شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا ايضا
من موسكو للمحل الاساسي في جيني
[موسيقى]
ضخمه جدا هي التداعيات التي خلفتها الحرب
في اوكرانيا على الاقتصاد الاوروبي
والبريطاني على حد سوى اذ توقع البنك
الدولي الا يسجل الاقتصاد الاوروبي نموا
هذه السنه كما ان بريطانيا هي الدوله
الصناعيه الوحيده المرشحه للتسجيل انكماش
هذا العام حسب صندوق النقد الدولي
الحرب في اوكرانيا ادت الى تباطؤ النشاط
الاقتصادي في اوروبا بسبب تعطيل سلاسل
التوريد وتراجع الثقام حيث يتوقع البنك
الدولي الا يسجل الاقتصاد الاوروبي اي نمو
هذه السنه وما بريطانيا فهي الدوله
الصناعيه الوحيده المرشحه للانكماش هذه
السنه كما ان اسعار الغذاء وصلت الى اعلى
مستوى لها على الاطلاق في مارس عام 2022
مع بدء العمليات العسكريه ولكن الضرر
الاكبر كان الارتفاع الحاد في اسعار
الطاقه الذي ادى الى تضاعف اسعار
المستهلكين اربع مرات مقارنه بعام 20 21
ويقدر بعض الخبراء ان الحرب شطبت نقطتين
مئويتين من نمو الاقتصاد الاوروبي
يمكننا ان نقيس اثر الحرب بشكل مباشر على
فواتير الطاقه عند الذروه في بريطانيا
مثلا تكلفه الطاقه ارتفعت اربعه في المئه
في فرنسا كان رقم اقل بسبب الطاقه النوويه
ولكن في المانيا كان الرقم اعلى من
بريطانيا وبالتالي نحو نصف الارتفاع في
التضخم كان ناتجا بشكل مباشر عن الحرب
صدمه الحرب دفعت العديد من البلدان
الاوروبيه لتقليل اعتمادها على روسيا
لتحصيل الطاقه المانيا التي كانت تعتمد
على روسيا لتحصيل النصف امداداتها من
الغاز والثلث الامدادات النفطيه قامت
بتنويع مصادر الطاقه لدرجه انها لا تعتمد
اليوم على روسيا بحسب وزير الماليه
ايطاليا بدورها قلصت والدتها من الغاز
الروسي من 40% الى 25%
مع الاسف الحرب في اوكرانيا مستمره ولكن
اثر الحرب على اوروبا تتراجع لان الناس
بدات تتعايش مع غياب الغاز الروسي وحتى
اذا كان هناك ضعف في النمو هذه السنه نحن
لا نتوقع انكماشا اقتصاديا شديدا وهذا
افضل من توقعاتنا السابقه
وجدير بالذكر انه على الرغم من كل تلك
الجهود لتقليل الاعتماد على روسيا الى ان
ازمه طاقه ادت الى افلاس العديد من
الشركات والمنشات الصناعيه ضربه قاسيه
طلاقات اقتصادات الدول الاوروبيه
وبريطانيا بسبب الحرب الاوكرانيه خلال
السنه الماضيه ومع استمرار الصراع العسكري
تعمل تلك البلدان على تعايش مع الواقع
الجديد ايميله ان تعود الى مسار التعافي
لاحقا هذه السنه كارينا كامل العربيه لندن
لا مشاهدين هذه التغطيه متواصله بعد قليل
من قناه العربيه ولكن اطيب التحيات
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[موسيقى]